religious clergy pursue secular clergy
yes of course one thing is the
institutional structure of churches and
not religion other thing is the extent
to which there are ethics precisely
social ethics political ethics and this
is what the work of Max Weber is
interesting because in the one hand he
claimed that there are carriers of his
religion which are kind of the key that
have shaped the religion but then there
is a dynamic ones religion was in a
particular direction that has a specific
social ethics specific political ethics
etc and we see that obviously
Catholicism is not only whatever the
Pope in Rome says there are all kinds of
dynamics which are carefully given when
they are within the church Charles
Taylor is a great Catholic thinker
whether he you know mr. Lee irrelevant
whether he is he's a heretic of course
but a great Catholic thing great
pathology and there is a Catholic
tradition which is part of this so um
but he so visit that cut probably
whether he goes to church or not I don't
know and I don't care but this is not
the issue that indeed we think in
certain ways and there are ways of
thinking that are part of these
processes and of course the interesting
question is how we all the whole globe
all these competing ethics as we enter
into as long as we all live separately
we all could have our own ethics and who
couldn't care but we are going to enter
into a situation which will have to make
the globe as a whole very serious
questions question in bioethics concern
environmental issues and these ethical
traditions are going to influence
influence these debates so as more and
more it will be in our hands and in
scientific hands to open up pandora
boxx's in the process of solving
problems then we'll have to have all
kinds of ethical discussions in which
the different ethical traditions of
humanity are going to have to
participate because nobody's going to be
able to impose a solution on anybody but
the idea that somehow this has to be
only precisely because of the you need a
secular global global secularity because
if you get the religion scene is a mess
well no because this global secularity
we know is a form of Western Christian
secularity and there are people are not
going to accept it as really global in
cosmopolitan and they will see this
somewhat Christian
so